- [Mushfiq] Sarah and
Jennifer who are both
from George Washington
and they have expertise in economic
and global health and public health.
And I'm especially excited to hear
from them because we
have been collaborating
at one of the sites where
they've been collecting data
in Bangladesh but we'll
hear about the work
that they're doing in multiple
sites around the world.
And I guess today we will
talk a lot about Jordan and Bangladesh
And so thanks very much
Sarah and Jennifer for being with us.
And, hopefully like I remember we actually
originally scheduled this to be in person
but hopefully at some
point we can fix that.
- Great well, thanks very much,
Mushfiq for the invitation
and thanks for the
opportunity to present today
and Ramadan Mubarak to
those of you that observe.
So Jennifer and I will be
sharing the presentation today
talking about findings from
our research on adolescents
in Bangladesh, in Jordan, that's part
of the gender and adolescents
global evidence study.
These findings are on behalf
of a large research team with researchers
in the US, UK, Bangladesh,
Jordan, Palestine and others.
And I'll provide a link
to the website at the
end of the presentation.
So you can learn more about
the broad collaboration
Jennifer and I are both
relatively new to research
in refugee settings.
So we're particularly delighted
to be presenting to this group.
And we really look
forward to your questions
and insights on you know,
new strands of research
we may wanna pursue in the future.
Also, you know, we're, this is
a very collaborative project.
And so we hope that
this also opens up scope
for future collaboration.
So what we've decided to do
today is to provide kind of
an overview of the GAGE project
and some of the research
Jennifer and I are working on
I think it sort of just highlights broadly
what we're doing and
hopefully provides you
you know, you learn something new
and are excited to hear more
as this research progresses.
I'll start by providing
an overview of GAGE
'cause I imagine many of you are new
to the Gender and Adolescents
Global Evidence project
as well as why we think our adolescents
are an important age group
to study, particularly
in refugee context, I'll then
turn to a detailed description
of our samples in Bangladesh and Jordan
which will be the focus
today, as much as it mentioned
we're lucky enough to
partner with him in Austin
and others on the Cox's Bazar Panel Survey
which is where the
Bangladesh data comes from.
And then gonna hand it over to Jennifer
who's going to talk about findings related
to three specific adolescent capabilities
that map to our GAGE conceptual framework
which we'll about in a bit
we decided to focus on
education, bodily integrity
which includes violence and child marriage
as well as psychosocial wellbeing.
Jennifer will talk about sort of the risk
and protective factors
for improved outcomes.
Diving deep into analysis
on mental health.
She'll also explore the role
of adolescent programming
in promoting resilience
and sort of mitigating the
impact of negative shocks.
She'll then hand it back to
me where I will talk a bit
about our COVID-19
research in both contexts
and how that is exacerbating
existing inequalities
for these groups and then
I'll turn to some conclusions.
We're happy to take questions throughout
and we'll also try and pause,
you know, every 10 minutes
or so to open it up for any questions.
I want to know from the
start that, you know,
although Jennifer and
I are both economists
and typically focus on
randomized control trials
and causal inference that today
our presentation will
largely be descriptive
in nature, really building
on the robust baseline data
we have in these contexts
we will compliment this with some
new measurement work
some work combined engaged
data with administrative data
and some quasi experimental analysis.
We also have very rich qualitative data
that supports our quantitative data
which I think allows us to dig deeper
on certain things that
perhaps typical studies
that are not able to dig into.
And so from there, let's
go to the next slide.
So let me just first
provide an overview of
of the GAGE research agenda
which these two samples fit into.
Since I think probably for many of you
you're not familiar with this study.
Next slide.
So GAGE is a nine year mixed methods
longitudinal research program
exploring the gendered
experience of adolescents
10 to 19 years globally.
We're following around
18,000 adolescents close
to 20,000 boys and girls in
sort of seven focal countries.
So Ethiopia and Rwanda,
Nepal and Bangladesh
and then Palestine, Lebanon and Jordan.
Ultimately GAGE is interested
in exploring what works
for whom, where and why.
So we can better support adolescent girls
and boys in the future.
The GAGE I think in particular
is focused on the most
vulnerable adolescents.
So this includes working with
refugee populations, but also
over sampling adolescent
girls who experienced child
marriage and adolescents with disability.
So we can actually kind of quantitatively
say something about these groups.
I should note that GAGE is funded by SCDO
in the UK and led by the
overseas development Institute
in the UK and Jennifer and
I lead on the quantitative.
Next slide
So GAGE is guided by a,
what we call the 3Cs
conceptual framework.
So capabilities, context,
and change pathways.
This has been really important
in ensuring that these very
varied research streams
both in terms of context
we're working in programs,
we're evaluating partnerships
et cetera, sort of map
onto some overall framework
that helps speak more
broadly to not only what
how adolescents transition
from young adolescents
to adulthood, but also
how context interacts
with that without transition.
Our conceptual framework
is built around six core
capability domains that
you see listed here.
This draws on a marquee
ascends work who argued that to
achieve a dignified life people
need a sort of core set of
entitlements for freedoms
which he called capabilities
and GAGE will identified
these six as capability areas
that are particularly
salient for adolescents.
And as I mentioned on the
previous slide, we're gonna
focus sort of dive deeper
into three of them today.
I think given both time
constraints and given where
we sort of see the most
differences between Jordan
and Bangladesh, as well
as where we actually see
some similarities.
This framework recognizes
that adolescents context
at the household community
and national level
are gonna shape outcomes.
And I think that's gonna
be really highlighted
in our findings today.
And it also highlights the importance
of reaching adolescents through
different policies and programs.
And we'll speak to some
of that today as well.
And happy to talk to
more about this later on.
Next slide.
As I mentioned we're
falling approximately 20,000
adolescents globally.
These include quantitative
survey girls and boys
themselves who in most
cohorts were age 10 to 12
or 15 to 17 when the research started.
We also survey female and male caregivers,
as well as community leaders, schools
health facilities, et cetera,
to better understand the context
these adolescents live in.
The quantitative data is supported
by qualitative research and
annual participatory research.
The qualitative data is extremely detailed
methodologies and you know,
Jennifer and I, neither Jennifer
and I are our quantitative
or qualitative experts
but we're going to also highlight
support our quantitative
findings with some
of the work that's coming
out of the qualitative side.
Next slide.
I might just quickly motivate
why we're focused on adolescents.
Why is this sort of an
interesting group to look at
particularly in refugee contexts?
So adolescence is a time where physical
transformations are large, right?
They're going through puberty.
And in addition, children's
place in the household
trains is dramatically and
it changes very differently
for boys and girls, right?
Gender norm has become
more, much more salient
than this time.
It's also time adolescents are probably
vulnerable to a wide range
of risk-taking behavior that could
jeopardize long-term outcomes.
But this sort of malleability also ensures
that this is a time where intervention
maybe particularly salient is why
and so why we search this
investor have now called
on adolescents has kind
of a window of opportunity
for intervention, right?
So building on the first, 1000 days to say
this is another key touch
point where intervention
may be critical to
promote improved outcomes
as adolescent age, you think, you know
reaching adolescents,
not only because of the
there are sort of the
importance to good outcomes
in adulthood, but adolescents
are also a massive proportion
of the population, right?
And that's growing.
So reaching adolescents
is going to be critical
for achieving the sustainable
development goals.
And so we really need to understand more
about their lives across various contexts.
Next slide.
Adolescence specifically,
but also refugees are our key population
for sustainable development goal delivery.
This is not an exhaustive list,
but we listed here a subset
of the sustainable development goals
and how ensuring that refugees are
looked at and considered
as an important group
to reach these goals
across these different domains.
This again is further emphasized
by adolescents where the
proportion of young people
among the display displays
is disproportionate, right?
So when we look at the kind
of displaced population
globally about 50% are children
as opposed to 30% of
the global population.
In Jordan specifically who have taken
in more than a million Syrian refugees
nearly a half are below the age of 18.
Similarly in the refugees
and in Bangladesh over
450,000 are children.
And 55% are under the age of 18.
So sort of adolescents refugee adolescents
are sort of a critical group
to understand in order to meet
the sustainable development goals.
- [Mushfiq] Can I interrupt?
I was just wondering
as you were speaking about
refugees and adolescents
whether there's any biological
or physiological reasons
for us to believe that
the act of displacement
or instability or exposure
to violence, right?
Which often predates like displacement
is that differentially harmful
for adolescents relative
to the adults or relative
to younger children
just getting a sense of during
like critical growth phases.
What these types of kind of
attacks on people's psyche
and their physical
health might do to them?
- Yeah great question.
So, you know, I think
obviously there's the shock
of forced displacement
affects all age groups
and in different ways,
I think for adolescents
a few critical things, one, it often leads
to fairly severe disruptions
in education, right?
So they're sort of either
out of school, permanently
or out of school for long
periods of time that's
in and of itself problematic
for improved adult outcomes.
But also, you know, particularly
for girls can lead to early
marriage early childbearing
which has its own set
of health consequences.
And for boys can end
up in child labor again
with potential physical
health consequences.
Another particularly critical point
for adolescents is mental
health issues are one
of the leading causes of
disability among adolescents with
I think alongside, I'm going to forget
but basically it's one
of the top three causes.
And so we know, and we
also know that the majority
of mental health illnesses
in adulthood start in adolescence.
And so we can see how these
sort of negative shocks
from violence leading to higher symptoms
of psychosocial distress
and adolescents can then lead
to longer term consequences.
And Jennifer is gonna speak
directly to the association
between past exposure to violence
and current mental health.
And then just finally, I think
the other point is, you know
we increasingly recognize the importance
of nutrition during adolescents
and there's a lot sort of
innovative new research
around an adolescent growth spurt, right?
So if you've missed out in childhood
you may actually be able to catch
up if you intervene
appropriately, we had adolescent.
So again, adolescents going
through forced displacement
awfully lack access to
enough nutritious food
which again is challenging.
So I think there are lots of reasons why
adolescents are gonna face
certain important consequences
from forced displacement.
- [Mushfiq] Sorry to extend
the conversation a little bit
but I'm picking up from your response.
So it reminds me of, so
this is my own version
of really low quality
qualitative data work
which is like just having conversations
in the Rohingya refugee camps,
the same places where you
and I are data with some, you know
knowledgeable individuals
within the camp growing up
growing an individual.
So one of the complaints
in Bangladesh then, oh, you
know, these Rohingya, I mean
so people initially thankfully
welcomed the refugees
like remembering that we
were refugees once, but then
as you probably know that over
time, people have gotten more
and more and annoyed for
like just getting fed up
with the situation and
that, you know, a lot
of our land is taken up and
there's no long-term solution.
You know, we don't see
repatriation as an effect
as a feasible solution to
what's going to happen.
And so one of, you know
so there've been many complaints
that have been merging.
And one of the complaints is
that fertility rates among
Rohingya are very high
and you know, they have too many children
they have children early, et cetera.
So when you were talking
about early marriage with et cetera right?
So a person who has a university
education was running up
but studied a number
of neither university.
So he was trying to explain
to me what exactly goes on there.
And his explanation was
that when the military right
used to come in at the top model attack,
the villages, right?
They often had, because rape was used
as one of the weapons, right.
They often had their eyes on young girls.
And one of the, I guess
the defensive strategies
that they're going to develop
is that whenever somebody is
of age, like an adolescent,
like they get married
off and they try to get
pregnant as quickly as possible
because that would be a
way to protect young girls.
- Yeah so, I mean, I think
that resonates with Jordan as
well was I think child
well, so I think two things
I think one, given concerns
of rape, whether by, you know
government forces or
simply by other people
in the community, I think there's a sense
of trying to ensure
that the girl is married
and et cetera, to protect her
from that possible violation.
And then in second, I think
in these contexts is also
seen as a way to get additional
financial support, right.
Social means sort of social
protection mechanisms.
So I think in both of these contexts
we're seeing increased
rates of child marriage, as
for example, in Jordan,
for example, as some
of the more global support dissipated,
sort of there was a
spike in child marriage
'cause these households were looking
for other ways to support.
So I think there's sort of
a sexual purity piece of it.
And then as well as in sort
of a protection around risks
of rape, as well as a
social protection angle
Jennifer, do you want to add?
- Yeah I was just going to
say, don't have it in the
presentation here, but I've
been working on a paper around
early marriage and the
row among the rucking men
in the camps and in the
qualitative work there.
One of the things that came
out very strongly was exactly
this issue that you discussed
which is early marriage as
a way to protect the girls
from gender based violence
and sexual violence
even continuing to occur
in the camps as well.
And I have a couple of
stats on a few slides too.
- Okay great.
So now I'm gonna talk a little bit more
about our sample.
Next slide.
Great so in Jordan, we have a
little over 4,000 adolescents,
Syrians, vulnerable Jordanians,
Palestinians in Gaza camp
as well as a small handful
of other nationalities.
So Iraqi, Pakistani, et cetera,
these adolescents were sampled
from UNICEF and UNHCR lists.
So they should be considered
sort of representative globally
of adolescents in camps and
informal tented settlements.
So ITS are Informal Tented Settlements
basically anyone living in a camp,
its would be in one of
these UNICEF in UNHCR lists.
And then it should be
considered representative
of kind of vulnerable Jordanians
and Syrians in host communities.
The Syrians live in host formal camps
and informal tented settlements
but Jordanians live in host communities
and the Palestinians live in
one specific camp Gaza camp.
The Syrians live in Zachary and Azraq camp
in our sample.
At baseline, which was in late 2018.
The majority of girls and boys
were 10 to 12 and 15 to 17.
And you can see sort of
fairly equal distributions
by gender and age.
And we also have, as I mentioned,
over-sampled adolescents
with disability and many
got lessons to be able to
kind of speak directly to those groups.
In host communities we're
working in four localities,
Amman, Mafraq, Arabic and Geraci.
So again, the Jordan sample
should be thought of as
broadly representative
of vulnerable adolescents
in camp hosts and its communities.
Next slide.
Yeah so as I mentioned, our
original survey took place
in 2018, 2019 when the majority
were 10 to 12 and 15 to 17
along with adolescent
surveys, we surveyed primary
female caregivers and also
conducted a school-based survey.
We were then in, I was in
Jordan in late February, 2020.
We were about to launch our
second round of data collection.
And literally the day we were
supposed to go to the fields
Jordan went into a strict
lockdown around COVID 19.
So we pivoted and conducted virtual
surveys in may in July, 2020.
And then again in October,
2020 in January, 2021.
This is a sample where 99%
of households have access
to a cell phone or landline.
And so it's a kind of a place as well.
That's very conducive to
conducting virtual surveys.
And although these surveyed
rates, you know, 75%
to 72% maybe lower than what you would see
in-person surveys, I
think they look relatively
good for COVID surveys
and analysis suggests
that the we're sort of
missing adolescents largely
at random, other than being slightly more
likely to find adolescents
from the younger cohort.
Next slide.
I thought it might be helpful to just
provide some baseline characteristics
from the sample that has helped
orient you to who these are
and how they kind of vary across context.
So I think one important
thing that I hope comes
out of our presentation
today is not only the sort
of variation between sort
of the refugee experience
in Bangladesh versus Jordan,
but also within these contexts
how buried it can be by by
gender and other characteristics.
So first is just looking
at social protection.
So whether the household
receives food or cash aid
you can see that the majority
of Syrians do have access to some sort
of social protection support
with much lower rates
for Palestinians and
Jordans and Jordanians.
But you can also see when you look
at location of residence for Syrians
that social protection is
basically universal in the camps
drops a little bit in
host and drops further.
And one thing that we'll see
in Jordan is that that the sort
of social safety net system
of the camp actually
provides Syrians in camps
a lot more support than in hosts.
And I think that's gonna
contrast to sort of
the camp experience in Bangladesh.
Does that anything to highlight
is just to get a sense
of school enrollment, about three quarters
of the sample work in school
at baseline much lower rates among Syrians
than compared to
Palestinian and Jordanians.
And again, we see that
rates are slightly higher
on camp followed by host,
but then dramatically lower
in informal tented
settlements were only 42% were
in school speaking
to the specific
vulnerability of that group.
Next slide.
Similarly, when we look at
gender and marital status
mobility is sort of a important issue
for these populations
and this has become increasingly apparent
with the COVID research.
So at baseline, 76%
of the adolescents were
able to leave their house
on a daily basis.
But then you see this sort
of massive gender divide
87% of boys versus 67% of girls.
And then when we look at the
older girls by marital status
we can see that married girls have very
little ability to move around, right?
So only 28% of them were
able to leave their house
on a daily basis.
Similarly, when we break
school enrollment down
by gender and marital status,
so one is we actually see
that schooling rates are similar
by boys for boys and girls
and actually across the board
education outcomes in Jordan
whether it's a Romant
attainment, et cetera
tend to actually benefit girls over boys.
Once again, we see that
that marriage girls not
surprisingly are very unlikely
to still be in school.
And that's sort of another group
with specific vulnerabilities.
Next slide.
So now very quickly, and Jennifer's gonna
dive a lot more deeper
into these findings.
So as I mentioned, where we
partner with with Mushfiq
on the Cox's Bazar Panel
Survey, which includes a sample
of Rohingya in the camps, as
well as Bangladeshis in sort of
near hosts and further hosts communities
are the GAGE's piece of the sample.
Once again, focuses on adolescents,
tend to 12 and 15 to 17
with again, over sampling
of adolescents with disabilities
and married adolescents.
There's a very detailed listing
and sampling process to sort
of ensure representation
that these samples are
broadly representative
of the camps and the host with
a couple of exceptions where
we're unable to do surveys
and a couple of the camps.
Next slide.
So our sample here is a little
over 2000 adolescents were first surveyed
in sort of mid to late 2019.
Once again, we also surveyed
primary female caregivers.
What's really nice here is
that this data set links to
much fixed broader data set
which has a lot of households
and adult level information.
Both of those data sets are
now in the public domain.
So I think lots
of additional research can
be done exploiting much
like an Austin's data or Jennifer
and my data and linking the two as needed.
So it's really been
great sort of a great way
to partner on surveys, interested
in similar populations,
but different questions.
So once again, we also have to pivot
to virtual surveys here, which
while in host communities
is doable, was particularly
challenging in camps.
And I think it's something
we're gonna have to think
about more as we move
forward, but you know
we did reach about 70% at COVID round one
and COVID round two is
actually ongoing now.
So we won't be able to report yet
on that second virtual survey round.
Next slide
Just to give you a sense
of who this population is.
I think, you know, first
and foremost are really
important facts about
the Rohingya is they
basically have no access
to formal education in the camps.
And so you can see that camp, which
is sort of synonymous for wrangle and
like 3.7% are enrolled in
any kind of formal school.
They do have access to
some informal schooling
but that's fairly limited
and Jennifer will speak to that as well.
We also see that child marriage
is much among the sample
than it is in post with
again, the majority
of marriages happening for girls
and very few for adolescent boys.
Similar to the note on
inability on the first slide,
we also see, you know
that these adolescents
have some limited mobility here.
Once again, this sort
of massive gender divide
with 78% of boys versus 44%
of girls being able to
leave their camp block
or host community at least once per week.
And so they, you know
these adolescents are living
fairly constrained lives.
So any questions on the sample
before I hand it over to Jennifer to dig
into some of our findings?
All right, Jennifer, over to you.
- Thank you.
All right.
So now I'm going to start
talking a little bit
about adolescent capabilities.
As Sarah mentioned previously,
I'm gonna be focusing
in on education and
learning bodily integrity
with a look at exposure to violence
and early marriage and then
psychosocial wellbeing.
And within the discussion of capabilities
I will also talk a little
bit about some of the
quasi experimental work we're
doing evaluating programming
that's happening both in Jordan
and in the Rohingya camps.
And then I'll do a deep dive sort of
into psychosocial mental health outcomes
and exposure to violence, pre migration.
So first sort of starting
with education and learning.
I wanted to start on a
positive note, which is that
you know, adolescent
aspirations are quite high
in both of these contexts.
So when both Jordan and
Bangladesh, we see, you know
Jordan 80, over 80% of
adolescents wanna complete
at least some secondary
school and in Bangladesh
and our sample over 90% of
adolescents want to complete
at least some secondary school,
but there's you know,
variation across populations
even within the various context.
So in Jordan, you know, the
lowest level of aspirations
for secondary school is 60%
of adolescents living in these
in ITS in the tented communities
versus 93% of Jordanian girls.
And then really where the
stark difference comes in
is aspirations for at
least some university.
So, whereas in Jordan, you know
70% of adolescents want to complete
at least some university in Bangladesh.
We see in this sample
in Cox's Bazar among the Bangladeshians
and Rohingya adolescents
only about 45% aspire
to at least some university,
but this is, you know
driven by wide disparities
and in populations.
So in particular, Rohingya
girls have very low aspirations
for university attendance
which is likely partially reflective
of like the realities of what
will be possible for them.
And as I'll be discussing sort of access
to education is basically
non-existent for that population.
The other thing I wanted
to point out is that,
well actually I'll get
to that the next slide.
So then I also wanted to point out that
you know, parental aspirations largely
reflect the adolescent
aspirations themselves
female caregivers, over
95% in both contexts
want their child to attend at
least some secondary school.
And then for university attendance
sort of reflecting what
we saw among adolescents,
adolescents, you know, 88%
of parents are supportive
of a university education
in Jordan versus 32% of
parents in Bangladesh.
And again, why disparities between sort
of the Bangladeshi population
and the host communities
versus the Rohingya
population where, you know
only 15% of Rohingya parents are aspiring
for some university education.
I do wanna note that actually
even comparing the Bangladeshi population
in these host communities
to other contexts
in Bangladesh we also do work
in the slums around
Dhaka and in Chittagong
and select among school going
adolescents and aspirations.
And those contexts are much
higher for universities.
So in urban slums, about 71%
of female caregivers aspire
for university education
for their children and should have gone
to my new school going
adolescence it's about 93%.
So this also points
to the host communities that we're working
with in Cox's Bazar are also
relatively more vulnerable.
So I mentioned that,
you know, the disparity
in aspirations comes from
educational realities
and this points to access
to schooling for growth
Rohingya is well, formal
schooling is non-existent.
The Rohingya are restricted to camps
and are not allowed to
attend sort of local schools.
So the schooling that
they do have access to
are these informal learning centers
or temporary learning
centers that are set up
within the camps, which
we'll talk a bit about,
more about in a moment,
but they really cater
to younger adolescents
and children and the very
basic level education.
And then more generally
in these populations
restrictive gender norms prevent girls
from attending school once
they reach menstruation
and beyond, and you know, similar patterns
in Jordan in terms
of girls facing exclusion due
to restrictive gender norms.
But the picture in terms of access
to education for refugees
is a bit more positive.
So while initially Syrian
refugees faced some rates
of from education
Jordan introduced a
nationwide double shift system
that's increased access
to formal education among
the Syrian refugees.
And then they also have this
Makani non-formal education
platform that exists in
the camps, host communities
and tented settlements
that provide education.
So just to give a little bit more context
on these education programs
that exist in both contexts.
In Jordan this non-formal education
programming that's available
it's called Makani, which
translates to my space.
And it's a UNICEF program.
That's reached over a hundred
thousand vulnerable refugees
and host community children
in both host communities
and refugee camps.
And they have about 150 centers.
It's a comprehensive approach.
So part of the Makani
programming is around education
but it also is a well-rounded
approach providing
child protection services,
childhood development.
They wanna provide life skills
training and innovation labs
for adolescents and youth
as well as integrating health
and nutrition programming
through wash services.
And so as a whole, the Makani
programs aim to promote
and contribute to
children's youth and parents
full development and wellbeing sort of
across the board of, you know, physical
cognitive and socio-emotional wellbeing.
And so it's an integrative
program to improve wellbeing
among adolescents.
In Bangladesh, the main access
to education for the
Rohingya adolescents living
in the camps are these temporary
learning centers that have
are set up by UNICEF
and save the children.
And in partnership with the
government of Bangladesh
and temporary learning
centers are much more focused
on trying to provide learning progression
for children and adolescents
but very much focused on lower level, like
young children with the
learning and teaching
focusing on like learning
to read and letters.
And so, you know, our experience
with older adolescents through
qualitative interviews is
that they find the programs sort of boring
and like too low level.
And there was some discussion
about expanding these
temporary learning centers
to provide the Burmese curriculum
for the Rohingya
adolescents in Bangladesh.
And that was supposed to be
expanded in 2020, however
that was put on hold due
to the onset of COVID.
And in fact these
temporary learning centers
have been completely closed
since last year in April.
And so access to education is, again
essentially non-existent for adolescents.
So around both of these programs
we have done some work sort
of evaluating the impact
of these learning opportunities
and programming on adolescent outcomes.
And at this point
given that we just have,
you know, baseline data
we're comparing outcomes,
according to Makani participation
or the temporary learning
center participation.
And then we control for
factors that are relevant
to selection into participation.
So we're controlling for
age, sex and nationality
which had been found
in other literature to
be important drivers for participation.
And then in addition, we control
for household resources
through asset indices
whether the household had is literate
whether it's a female headed
household and the location.
And so in Jordan, that's in
a camp its or host community
and in Bangladesh, that's comparing
we're focused in the camps solely
for the temporary learning centers.
And so that's comparing
sort of techno to Uchida
which are the two puzzle is
where the camps are located.
And then we estimate when
we are doing this analysis
we also separate out our adolescents
into the two age cohorts,
10 to 14 year olds
and 15 to 17 year olds,
because both programs focus
on sort of adolescents
under the age of 15.
And most of Makani participants
are under the age of 10.
And then as I mentioned already
the TLC participation
is younger adolescents.
So first I just wanna talk a little bit
on access to education.
And I have a couple of figures here
which is estimated using the Jordan data
looking at the impact of Makani
and with the two figures.
The first is for the young
cohort, 10 to 14 year old
looking through a range
of education outcomes
including enrollment in formal
and non-formal schooling
as well as test scores
focusing a little bit on that scores.
And then the second figure
is for the older cohort
15 to 18 year olds.
And one of the things
I just wanna highlight
what you can see is that, you know
adolescents who are enrolled in Makani
or have ever been enrolled
in Makani are more likely
to be currently enrolled
in schooling and non-formal schooling and
that they tend to have better test scores
but that these seem to
be especially manifesting
for the older adolescents,
the 15 to 18 year olds, even
though they may not currently be enrolled
in the Makani sort of pointing
toward the supportive
role that Makani may have
played when they were
younger to carry them forward
for better outcomes in later adolescence.
And then we don't have as
wide of a range of outcomes
for the Rohingya camps, but
the temporary learning centers
also increase the likelihood of enrollment
in non-formal education by
about 64 percentage points.
Just to note that the temporary
learning centers account
for about 50% of the
enrollment in education,
sorry about 50% of
adolescents are enrolled
in the temporary learning centers
for the non formal education.
So a lot of this is
driven by the enrollment
and the non-formal education centers.
So now, you know, turning to
violence and here I'm gonna
talk a bit about more like
daily violence that adolescents
are facing in their lives.
- Sorry, just one question,
one question from the chat
before you go on, it's
just the question is do
the temporary learning
centers include child-friendly
spaces as well.
How exactly are they set up?
- Yeah, so they do have
child friendly spaces.
I will have to check specifically
on how those are structured and perhaps
when Sarah takes back over
in the second half and I can
come back to respond to that.
Thanks.
So in Jordan sort of day to day
experience of violence
in terms of reporting
from adolescents focuses
around sexual harassment
by adolescent girls as
is commonly reported
in the qualitative work
there's discussion of boys
and young men tend to stand
around outside girls schools
as they leave and follow them home.
And so this is a common occurrence.
Nearly half of the adolescents
are reporting violence
at home, and this is potentially, you know
violent discipline from parents
but this is much more heavily.
A higher burden is carried by boys
with 42% of boys mothers admitting
to using violent discipline compared
to 31% of girls mothers.
And we have a quote here
from a Syrian mother talking
about how she does not beat her daughter
because this will affect
her but when I beat my son,
he will be better.
That's sort of this few point
of variance and discipline
between male and female children.
And then bullying is common.
So 46% of 38% of girls report experiencing
peer violence which could include
like physical violence as well as needed.
The picture is really very
similar in Bangladesh where,
you know both camp and host communities
adolescent girls are
reporting sexual harassment
and gender based violence.
You know, 15% of married girls report
having experienced some form
of gender based violence.
And then again, peer violence
and bullying is common
with 45% of adolescents
experiencing peer violence.
And this is across both
camp and host communities.
So I would note that peer violence
is more commonly reported
in host communities in
this context where 54%
of adolescents reporting some form
of peer violence in host
communities versus 30% camps.
And one of the big challenge
in term of violence comes
with early marriage
and married adolescents
which we've already talked
a little bit about earlier
in the presentation, but just to reiterate
in Jordan 18% of the 15 to
17 year olds in the sample
almost entirely Syrian
were already married.
And in Bangladesh, the
share is a little lower,
but we found in our own sample
among 15 to 17 year old girls
about 12% of the females
were already married
and among married
adolescents in both Jordan
and Bangladesh among the
Rohingya refugee camps.
It qualitative work very
strongly presented evidence
of gender based violence.
And so I've chosen a selection
of quotes here from both communities.
These two quotes here, you know
girls are abused by their husbands
are both in Jordan context.
You know, he used to pour water in my ears
because these things don't
leave any marks on the outside
in the Rohingya camps, IPV
is happening within marriages
but it's very well known
even to unknown girls.
And so this is a quote
from a 16 year old
unmarried girl who says she
has heard a lot about
this from many persons
when wives don't listen to
their husbands, they're beaten.
And, you know, just to point out
that the solutions to these
are not well supported.
And so in the Rohingya
camps, there was a lot
of reporting that there's
no one reliable to report to
or they aren't listened
to when they do report.
And in Jordan, you know
one of the main outcomes is
divorced in these settings.
So in turning mental health
and then we'll kind of do a deeper dive
in our survey and what we focus on,
we're measuring mental health
primarily using the general
health questionnaire 12
which asks about how you've been feeling
in the last two weeks compared to normal.
And then we use the child
and youth resilience measure
to measure resilience.
And in Jordan, what we find
that most adolescents are not
psychologically distressed
and that they are emotionally resilient.
So I'm using the general
health questionnaire
12 to measure psychological distress
around a third of adolescents had scores
that demonstrated emotional distress
but this varied across populations.
And so in the Jordan
context, older girls are
11% more likely to be
distressed than older boys.
And in Bangladesh, you know,
rates of emotional distress
measured by the DHQ 12 are
much are lower around half
of what's recorded in
Jordan, but there are
significant differences between older
and younger adolescents
with, you know, 20%
of older adolescents reporting,
psychological distress
compared to 10% of younger adolescents.
And actually the most effected
group in Bangladesh is
around the older males and particularly
in the Rohingya camps and
in the qualitative work.
One of the major concerns that came
out is financial reasons.
And boys, you know, shouldering
the majority of the concern
about the, you know, work
that they need to do to
contribute to household incomes.
So again, kind of thinking
back to the programming
and what exists and how
we might be able to think
about supporting the psychosocial
wellbeing of adolescents.
We have looked at among
younger adolescents, the role
of the Makani programming and
the temporary learning centers
on, you know, resilience and
psychosocial mental health
as measured by the GHQ 12 and
what we find in both contexts
and misses particularly
driven by young boys.
And so these are the results
that I'm showing here is
that being currently enrolled
in Makani or currently
attending an NGO program,
reduces the GHQ 12 score
by about 0.3 points.
And in Bangladesh, this
translates to about an 11
percentage point reduction
in the likelihood
of experiencing psychological
distress, which is, you know
given that among young
adolescents as a whole around 10%
of them were experiencing
psychological distress.
This is quite a large
effect in that, you know
adolescents that are
engaging in this programming
are having better outcomes
suggesting that supportive environments
are crucial in these cases.
And then finally, I do just
wanna mention, you know, one
again, coming back to early marriage
and the negative impacts
that this has on adolescents, as you know
alongside gender-based violence.
One of the things that we
found in some recent work I've
been doing on are really married
to the Rohingya population
is that when you look at PHQ
nine scores, which is another
you know, clinical diagnostic
tool for a moderate
to severe depression, 37% of
our married adolescent girls
exhibit signs of moderate to
severe depression compared
to 11% of the older unmarried
girls in the Rohingya camps.
And so, you know, early
marriage, although maybe
potentially protective
is causing a fair amount of distress.
- Jennifer one question before you move on
so is divorced, socially acceptable
or are there some repercussions
for girls who get divorced?
Do they go back to live with their parents
as probably they're sort
of not economically active?
I can speak to Jordan in that it's
yes there is stigma associated
with being divorced and yes
they do typically go back
to live in their homes
but it has become so common.
So, you know, kind of, and these many
of these girls do then go into
marry again fairly quickly.
So yes, stigma, but at least in Jordan
has become very common.
And I don't know, Jennifer
if you can speak to Bangladesh.
- Yeah in the Rohingya context,
the divorce did not come up
strongly in the research
on early marriage.
And my understanding from the context
it's not socially acceptable
and so if it's not really
an option in that context.
- We have about 25 minutes left.
- Yeah so I've been, I think some
of this motivation slides I'll be going
through a little bit quickly
since we've already kind of
provided that motivation.
So what I want to talk about here
and I think I'll focus a little bit
on mental health and
measurement is some work
that we're doing using
children's drawings to measure
as potential measures of mental
health in these contexts.
So I have a few slides here
sort of motivating mental health
and adolescents which we
already discussed earlier
and, you know degrees of mental health
illness among refugees.
So I'll go through this quickly
but what I do want to stop and
talk about is that, you know
a big challenge in terms
of measuring mental health in
these contexts is, you know
how to assess psychological distress
for very young adolescents,
particularly when we're talking
about 10 and 12 year
olds, although, you know
the GHD 12 has been validated
in multiple populations
administering these complex
survey instruments in, you know
potentially fragile
contexts can be difficult.
And especially in cases
where adolescents have
limited education and are
struggling to understand concepts.
And so one promising
methodology is children's
self portraits and free drawings.
And these have been used in
clinical settings as a gauge of
of mental health and other contexts.
And there has been some recent research
using children's drawings
for measuring psychological
impacts in field studies.
And so we're building on this
to look at the feasibility
in our contexts as well.
So, you know, the empirical
literature has established link
between some characteristics
of children's self portraits
and free drawings and elements
of psychological health.
And I'll show some examples
of what that might look
like in a couple of slides.
And the nice thing about drawings is
that if we can associate, you
know, features of drawings
to mental health, we might
be able to learn things
about mental health that
would be difficult to obtain
from direct questioning either
because adolescents don't
want to respond directly
or don't understand the
concepts themselves.
And so what we're doing
with these drawings is
we basically give the
adolescents a sheet of paper
and a set of colored pencils
and a flat place to draw
and we give them simple instructions.
So we do both free drawings
in the GAGE context.
And then we have from another
data set, self portraits
but essentially the instructions are, I'd
like you to draw a picture
on this piece of paper,
using these pencils
and feel free to draw whatever
you're thinking about.
It can be a picture of anything
and they have 15 minutes.
And if it's a self portrait,
then we just specify that.
So we have these drawings
from two datasets among
Syrian refugee families.
And so one was collected in 2016.
Colleagues at university of San Francisco,
Bruce Wydick, Raphael, Penn, Leo
and I'm Stephanie Smith
collaborating with us on this work.
And then they have data on
children ages five to 12.
And then we have the GAGE Jordan data
that we've been talking about
today, focusing particularly
on the Syrian adolescents, aged 10 to 12
and for the USF dataset, we have portraits
and for the GAGE Jordan
dataset, we have free drawing.
And then we're able to do
surveys and collect information
on household characteristics
and governance of origin in Syria
and pair it with exposure
to trauma, which we
measure using the Syrian
Revolution Martyr database
which contains information on sort
of number of martyr deaths
in governance by, you
know, timing in Syria.
And so we're able to link
when adolescents traveled
to Jordan from Syria to sort of the timing
of martyr deaths in Syria
to measure the exposure
the extent of exposure
they've had to this violence.
And then in the future
we do have drawings and the
GAGE Bangladesh data as well
although it's currently
still in Bangladesh so
that we can bring that
into this work as well.
So just as an example of how features
of drawings might be used
to measure mental health.
So Tibbets 20 Tibbits
in some previous work
in 2013 has identified some features
of drawings that can be linked to PTSD.
And so some of those might be
like in this drawing of the
flag, you know, lack of concern
with integrating background
into drawing, perhaps, you know
focus on symbols or memories of trauma.
So that could be here is a picture it's
like a man aiming a gun at another person.
And so these are both features
that have been associated with PTSD.
And then there's other literature such
as work by Watson as
old, as far back as 1971
linking features of drawings
to anxiety and depression.
And so one might be drawn in dark colors.
So this is the black and white picture
of a hat or with a single color
of a house, excuse me, or even,
you know, positive features
of drawings indicating
low anxiety or happiness.
So having, you know,
bright colors, et cetera.
And so then this is how we've had
we had these drawings and we're
when we code them according
to these features and then
are able to classify them
into indicators of
depression, anxiety, or PTSD
that we then use as
measures of mental health.
And then we estimate the relationship
with these measures of
mental health that we build
from the indices using a simple regression
outcome is our index of
anxiety, depression or PTSD.
And then as our is a vector
of refugee experiences
that includes exposure
to violence or simulation.
And then we control for various
household characteristics.
And what we find is that
exposure to violence as measured
by the Syrian modern
database is positively
correlated or indicating higher levels
of PTSD as measured by
these drawing indexes,
both in the USF data among
the five to 12 year olds
in 2016 and in the GAGE Jordan data
measured more recently in 2018 and 2019.
And then in this data,
we're also able to measure integration
of the Syrian refugees
into the Jordan community.
So those living in host
communities, and we can see
that adolescents that
have been reintegrated
into Jordan society, that
this is these supportive
environments are
associated with reductions
in experience of PTSD and the USF data.
And then also reductions
in experience of depression
and anxiety across both data sets.
And so what we see is that
these measures of anxiety
depression, PTSD as indices of
mental health, sorry, indices
of drawing features are
associated with these violence.
So then what we wanna do is identify
in particular features of
these drawings that are
associated most associated
with exposure to violence.
And then whether these
same features of drawings
could be associated with
more traditional measures
of mental health, such as the GHQ 12.
And we do that using LASSO which is a tool
to identify basically the
most important correlates
with an outcome of interest.
And so we use LASSO to estimate
the following specification
where we have our outcome in this case
is now exposure to violence.
And we're trying to predict the violence
with drawing features, which
we have here in this D feature.
And we penalize these
drawing features in order to
identify the most important
drawing features in this case.
And then we have our control
variables that we don't
penalize characteristics.
And we estimate this
LASSO separately on each
of the two datasets, the USF
dataset and the GAGE dataset.
And what we find is in both cases
the drawing of aggressive
action figures is retained
as being highly predictive
of exposure to violence.
And so this is the most important feature,
but you can also see other
features that were retained
through the, through the LASSO estimation
in each data set as well,
including, you know, shading
a face of body monster
pictures as also being
positively correlated with violence.
And so what we're seeing is
that there are strong correlations
of these strong features
as being able to predict higher exposures
of violence measured
through the Syrian data.
And then just very quickly
we then took those features
that were identified
as predictive of violence,
and can also show
that they are correlated also
with signs of psychological distress
which we mainly point out here to say
that these features are
identifying something
that is correlated with
mental health as well.
So that we aren't just talking
about violence and drawing,
but also can really link
this back to mental health.
So I will wrap up there
and hand back to Sarah.
- Great, thanks Jennifer.
You know, I think there's
a number of questions
in the chat and I'll make
sure I leave, you know
five minutes to get back to these.
I mean, I think mental
health measurement in general
mental health measurement
among adolescents, you know
is something where continued
research is needed.
One thing that, you know, for example
it seems like some of
the rates of symptoms
of psychological distress are
lower among these populations
than typical adolescents in low
and middle income countries.
And that may be partially
because, you know
anxiety is such a it's
almost normalized for them.
And so I think we need to do
a bit more to figure that out.
And then I think, you know,
when there was a query
around access to serve as and I think
you know, yes, there's
stigma around mental health.
And then even if you identify it
there's limited access to services.
I know there are a lot of innovative
low cost methodologies being explored
but I really think this is you know
a place where a lot more
researches is needed.
Okay so I have about 10 minutes
so I'm not gonna really
do this part justice
but given that I think COVID-19
is on the top of our minds
and particularly given the
massive increases in cases
in Bangladesh as well
as in Jordan, I think
is typically salient for these settings.
I'm gonna skip most of these slides
but just highlight kind of
a few things that have come
out of our research.
Next slide.
So very quickly, just to, you know,
for those of you that press
don't work in these contexts
and haven't been following
what's happening with COVID
that'd be nice to just provide a graphic
of kind of the trajectory
of COVID-19 cases
over time and chemo policy moments
of most relevance for this conversation is
that when we conducted the first round
of COVID data collection back in May
Jordan had one of the most the
strictest lock downs globally
and cases were very very
low and when we resumed
our second round of
field work in late 2020,
early 2021, they had largely relaxed
those restrictions cases were
increasing pretty dramatically
and schools tried to reopen briefly
but then had to shut down.
And in fact, you know,
last March was actually
the highest case caseload
in Jordan thus far.
So there, I think it
things are starting to
turn, but sort of, you know
second round of data
collection was taken place
when there was a fairly high rise.
Next slide.
So in Bangladesh, it's I guess, sort of
a similar story when we
conducted data collection
in April, May, 2020, the
government had actually
imposed a very strict lockdown
on Cox's Bazar specifically
to prevent the spread of
the virus in the camps
this included closing
all the learning centers
and sort of other
non-essential NGO programs.
Data question, as I mentioned,
is still ongoing right now
but similarly cases are
rising dramatically.
Bangladesh announced another
lockdown on April 5th
with sort of a more severe
lockdown set to start
to tomorrow, complimenting this
there were actually horrible fires
in the camps sort of further, you know
preventing challenges on their lives.
And up to today, as far as I know
not a single Rohingya has
received a vaccination.
Next slide.
So you know adolescents obviously
are not really being affected
by the direct health impacts,
but school closures and the economic
disruption has been huge.
We collaboratives to develop a module
just asking for both the
adults and the adolescent
their perspective on how COVID
has impacted their community
across a variety of different dimensions.
And as you can see, almost everyone notes
that people have lost jobs
and schools have closed.
And also lots of people
noting increases in violence
people using shisha and
other types of substances
people unable to get medical care
and then issues around
self harm and suicide.
And this has also come out
in the qualitative work.
So this just highlights how dramatic this
the shock has been as
perceived by these households.
Next slide.
Similarly in Bangladesh.
So here, these are from
the adult's perspective
comparing and coast and camp.
And once again, you know
most households have effect had some sort
of employment or income
loss schools have closed
and people are perceiving,
you know, increased anxiety
increased violence, food
insecurity, et cetera.
So while the direct health
effects have not been
at least to date, perhaps as large
as they have been in
places like the US you know
the lockdowns in these
contexts have sort of
massively disrupted these people's lives.
Next slide..
So I'm gonna have to just
focus on a few key results.
This is the first one, which
is around food insecurity.
So we asked the adolescents
how many meals they had
with animal protein yesterday.
This also includes some
data from our other sites
and I guess, perhaps not
surprisingly given the magnitude
of the economic shock,
you can see that when
you compare baseline.
So this is pre COVID to
COVID round one, which is
the early pandemic and to
Jordan and COVID round two
you can see that the
number of meals with animal
protein dropped
substantially and in Jordan,
we still haven't seen
any sign of recovery.
So the economic effects
and then its translation
into food insecurity,
which has sort of much
and I were talking in the beginning.
I think the nutrition is
particularly important
for adolescent growth.
And so this is something
to be concerned about.
Next slide
In Jordan we can also further look at
differences in experiences
between host informal tented,
settlements, and camps here.
We're looking at whether
adolescents experienced hunger
in the last four weeks.
So again, you see these sort of increases
at COVID are one and
in both hosts and its
really no sign of recovery
but in camps you can see
that it does look like there
has been some improvement
and this points to the extensive
access to social protection
that adolescents have in camps that
is not there in hosts in ICF communities.
Next slide.
I'm not gonna do this justice,
but I really just want to
quickly note that Jordan has
actually done a fantastic job
relative to other countries
in terms of quickly pivoting
to online learning and given
the access to technology
et cetera, you can see that
many, most kids are able to
engage in some learning
through this ministry
of education program, even so you can see
through these qualitative
quotes that, you know
it's unclear how much learning
is actually happening.
And I think there's a lot of
concern about what happens when
schools reopen after
this sort of last year
of education.
But you know, again,
relative to other contexts,
Jordan has you know, I
think is exemplar in terms
of ability to pivot to online learning.
And I think benefits from
it's wide access to internet.
Next slide.
And Bangladesh you know,
it's a bit of the opposite.
So I'll just focus on
the purple shape, only 6%
of Bangladeshi's report
using any kind of media to
continue learning.
And there's literally only
one adolescent in our sample.
Who's had any sort of have access
to learning for media during the pandemic.
So this, you know, I think
highlights the fact
that the pandemic really
is going to exacerbate these
pre-existing inequalities
both across and within countries.
And we're going to need
to think of a programming.
That's gonna be
particularly focus on that.
Next slide.
Okay I guess quickly go through
a couple of final themes.
So, you know, we think a lot about
about school closures and how
that has isolated adolescents.
You know, Mr. Flick was
saying he had to come back
from the beach because
his son wanted to interact
with friends again and you know
social connectedness is
actually extremely important
for adolescents and
isolation is associated
with mental health,
anxiety and other outcomes.
So he did good by his son.
So this highlights
basically how isolated many
of these adolescents are
prior to the pandemic.
Pretty much everyone was
interacting with a friend
or non household member at
least once in the seven days.
But as you can see in
Jordan only about 30%
of both boys and girls were interacting
with friends at all, some
signs of recovery, right?
So we see by COVID round two
those numbers have
increased, but importantly
they increase a lot more
for boys than girls.
So girls are still are sort
of increasingly disadvantaged
in terms of these social connections.
And then looking
at the cost is our panel
survey for round one.
This really just highlights
the gender discrepancies
in social connectedness and how
how much girls have been
sort of socially isolated
from their networks.
And I think, you know,
alongside school return
we need to think about how we re-establish
the social connections.
Next slide,
Next slide.
So I very quickly on this.
So, you know, it sounds like
from the comments that a lot
of you were interested in
in sort of measurement issues as well.
So, you know, and so one
challenge we face inhibiting
to a virtual survey is we have a lot
of sensitive questions
and very rigorous policies
around connecting adolescents to services.
If they, you know, self-report, you know
whether it's exposure to
violence or something else.
And so we didn't feel
that we could adequately
protect their privacy or connect them
to services in the context
of the COVID-19 pandemic.
So instead of acting directly
about exposure to violence
we developed a series of
vignettes that basically asked
about whether a specific type
of violence was a challenge
for adolescents like them
and whether they thought it
had increased since COVID.
And so this kind of gives you a sense
of the types of questions
we're asking and, you know,
the proportion of the
population that was saying
that this was a challenge
that it increased
since COVID as a way to get a sense
of how the pandemic is affecting
violence, as well as things
like access to feminine hygiene products.
Next slide,
and just the same sort of set
of vignettes for, for Bangladesh.
And I think in general, you
know, highlighting violence
is pervasive and that
there has been some increases
since since COVID-19.
Next slide.
So I'll just end with this finding
before opening it up
for any final questions.
So, you know, there's a lot
of concern around whether
COVID-19 is going to
exacerbate child marriage, right?
So I think, you know, we've
highlighted the vulnerabilities
of girls who are already married
and our COVID-19 findings indicate that
they have been disproportionately affected
along many dimensions
but obviously there's also
concerned about currently
non-married girls and
whether this is going to
sort of accelerate their
transition to marriage.
Well, I think it's too early
in our quantitative
data to be able to look
at changes in marriage rates.
An interesting dichotomy
appeared when we asked them
whether they thought their
pressure to marry had decreased
or whether they worried
about marrying earlier.
We actually see that
quite a few adolescents
actually believe that
the pressure to marry
has decreased in both
Bangladesh and Jordan.
This could be for multiple reasons.
One is marriage brings a
financial burden and many
of these households simply
can't afford that right now
second marriage comes
with a ceremony and lots
of people gathering and COVID
doesn't allow that to happen.
And then third, you know,
sort of getting back to some
of the conversation Jennifer
and Mushfiq was having
as I think given that
girls are stuck at home
there's less concern about their sort
of sexual purity and their
exposure to kind of violence
outside of the household.
And so perhaps also a
little bit less rush to
get them married and have kids, et cetera.
On the other hand, you know,
we do have a other subset
of the population who are
concerned about marrying earlier.
And so it'll be, you know, one
of the beauties about
this data being embedded
in longitudinal work
is we'll be able to see
over time what actually happened
with marriage rates as a result of COVID
and whether, you know, this
we are actually seeing this dichotomy
and this actually comes out
in a lot of our COVID data is, you know
certain households saying
they're getting a lot
more support others saying
they're getting a lot less.
And so exploring those
dichotomies in attitudes
I think will be important
in looking at sort of post COVID recovery.
Next slide.
And if you can just go to the conclusions.
Right? So I basically, we highlighted some
of the vulnerabilities is
adolescents look at risk
and protective factors and
explored the impact of COVID.
You know, I think we
have a lot more to say
but hopefully this has
given you a broad sense
of what our research is about.
Next slide.
As I mentioned, you know,
this as long as, you know
work that will continue through 2024.
So we have one to two more
rounds in each context
to both look at post COVID
recovery, improve measures
and understand the
transitions to adulthood.
We're very deeply engaged
with policy makers globally
to ensure that research
findings inform policy
and programming, all data
will be publicly archived.
So, you know, this, as we go,
this data will be available for others.
And we do really welcome
broad multidisciplinary
collaboration and hope that
somebody will reach out
to us with, you know, with research ideas
or desire to collaborate.
Next slide.
There is ton of GAGE
publications on the website.
I encourage you to go look at it
if any of this has interest to you
and then final slide,
and just here's our contact information
and the website, and, you know
I really appreciate the discussion today.
'Cause I know I haven't been able
to get to all the questions
in the chat box, but I
realize we're out of time
but happy to follow up, you
know, for you to follow up
by email and happy to
answer those questions.
So really appreciate you
giving us the opportunity
to present these findings
and look forward to further discussions.
- Thank you, both Sarah and Jennifer
for the really nice presentation
and give an overview.
And I'll just add to that
that they've both been wonderful
people to collaborate with.
So this invitation to collaborate
that they sent out broadly,
I'm just endorsing the fact
that they were wonderful to work.